- Because I feel like you
have some kind of spidey sense
with singers.
Like, you know, I've
seen him on many shows
and I think there's something
about you, you can always
kind of recognize it.
Whether it's One
Direction, all those guys,
or Camila Cabello, me, there's too many,
I could name so many.
But what do you,
what do you think you catch
that maybe nobody else does?
- For me, you can see it in people's eyes.
You know?
It's like, if you've got
that kind of, it's something
when you look in someone's
eyes when they audition,
you're like fearless.
And even if it's not perfect,
this is just something
you recognize.
I wouldn't say I get it
right a hundred percent.
But most times-
- You get it right a lot-
- I've got a pretty good track
record and that's what I do.
I look in someone's eyes
and I can see whether
they're confident or not.
And whether they've got great
taste is another part of it.
Because a lot of time people come on
with the wrong song choices.
- Song selection.
- Why did you choose that song?
Or why didn't you do
something creative with it?
I mean, that's when I get
frustrated, but look, it's hard,
but it's still the most
amazing feeling, you know?
When you always remember
that audition, when
you meet the star for the first
time and that's, you know,
genuinely why I still do the job now.
- That's gotta be so cool
too, that you see so young.
Like I was 19, a lot of those
like One Direction boys, they were really,
they were younger than that.
Like, and then you see them now
and they all have their separate careers
and they're all, that's just crazy.
- Oh, amazing, and Camila was,
she wasn't even meant to audition.
She wasn't, I think we were like
on time or something that particular day
which meant when she was a reserve
and I went backstage to have a cigarette
and she was lying on the floor crying.
I went what's the matter.
She said they weren't let me audition.
And I went, well, just go and audition.
So she came out five minutes later.
Amazing.